what's up everybody today i am baking
where's my partner i'm alone
[Music]
i have a cooking partner today and she
goes by the name of
julia julia julia
julia julia's here with us today we are
going to be making
chinese egg tarts or is it portuguese
egg tarts which one are we doing okay
portuguese egg tarts i think we are like
on the lookout for the best portuguese
egg tarts i've ever had and i think the
one that we've had
is jan's bakery park that one is so
good you actually bought some yesterday
yeah on set from jk news
for research yes it was it was amazing
research by the way yeah so i have a
egg tart video on this channel let me
know what you think if you've tried it
but
julia actually tried making egg tarts
recently we are now trying to combine
forces to see if we can perfect the egg
tart yeah
judge yes on a scale of one and ten how
much do you like the egg tarts
on a scale from one to ten about an
eight
seven maybe seven i'll give it a seven
solid [ __ ] okay so you like this food
item
oh bow ties right that's a ten man those
are bombs
they're really good but the ones that i
tried from
this household they're like a solid like
a solid four okay okay okay to redeem
yourself
we have room to grow we have room to
grow okay okay
you can only go up true true true no i
agree because
for me egg tarts need to be like a
gelatinous like the
if you ever bite into one and then you
like wiggle the egg tart
it's supposed to kind of like jiggle a
little bit like a jello was mainly mine
don't do that
the pastry part was like rock part like
it's just not it wasn't flaky
it didn't really like you know it didn't
do its thing but it's not just me saying
this you said this too
you agreed you were like yeah i could do
a lot better
which is actually where julia perfects
her her craft
is in the pastry part yes so so when
julie and i made our own
egg tarts on our own i did store-bought
pastries and i made the custard myself
whereas julia actually made the pastries
and the custard
and it's so much harder isn't it i mean
the only the only hurdle we have
is the pastry crust and that's like the
longest part but i think when i was
making it under the condition that i had
was that the
countertop space is really small and you
have to like roll it out really thin
and then you have to fold the butter
into it right yeah and i didn't have
that and also another thing that was
against me was that there was no ac in
the house so it was really warm and so
the dough was just kind of like
getting all like melting on you i feel
like i couldn't i couldn't fold them
properly and anything but that but
the crust wasn't bad though so casey
earlier today he got some ingredients
and then we were about to start i was
looking at the ingredients that he got
and i was like
no no no no no no i had this the entire
time you did not have this okay look
this is what he had all right so the
recipe calls for all-purpose flour
and so when let's see so when he was
like oh yeah i got flour
we're good and i looked at the flower
and i was like
rising do you know what he said he was
like oh this is self-rising flower all
personal all the same thing
it should be same thing no wonder you
struggle at baking
it's you know you know i'm a chef i like
to substitute stuff you know have some
fun
but apparently when you bake you don't
substitute anything it's more like a
it's an exact science it's a sweet
science i'm learning that the hard way
julia's here to school me i don't know
if i could school you but we could do
this again you know your baking stuff
like you
jakey newsdays we have had some awesome
julia surprises uh you've brought in
like fruit tarts before
that's my favorite yeah you made some
some amazing stuff and like every time
you bring it in i'm like where'd you get
it from and then you're like no i didn't
i didn't get anywhere
i made it the fact that it's homemade
and and you made it out of love for us
like
that was that was always a very sweet
gesture for me thanks
yeah i always wondered like what what
you guys actually thought about it
because i feel like people would just be
nice because oh yeah this is good
this is good i was like but is it really
good though it is kind of
feedback point is we're here to make my
egg tarts better
and uh we'll see what happens at the end
of the day
a quick question so when i make my egg
tarts they always seem like they're
exploding inside my oven
where your where yours exploding inside
the oven like they were just like
no i didn't see that but i also felt
like i overcooked my custard
prior to baking it though like it was
very um
it kind of had a very curdled texture by
the time we ate it
what does curdles mean for everyone that
else that doesn't know i don't really
know what that means either
it's like i don't it's like it's like
thick and like the egg is cooked so it's
not like
it's gelatinous like smoothies the
wiggle yeah we're looking we're looking
for the wiggle
but it doesn't do them ours is just kind
of like stuck yeah yeah it's like a
cloth so i was like
so we're gonna get started right now
yeah and uh first things first and the
hardest part of the whole process of
making egg tarts if you're making it
from scratch
is the pastry part so we are now going
to be folding butter
into flour are you supposed to like
take a take a knife or something and
like scoop like scrape the top to
level it like completely flat to make it
like perfect typically what i do is that
if the cup fits into the bag i have to
scoop it and then use the bag edge to
like
top it oh i see i see okay to make sure
that i get it all
that's their rounded measurement julia i
think you're doing it wrong
i'm glad i reminded julia that in baking
we don't do rounded measurements because
that was clearly a rounded measurement
[Music]
cool i never use that thing the only
person in this household that actually
uses that thing
is tiff oh really yeah i don't do much
baking
it's fun it's just so hard because i've
tried making bread and i think my
experience of making my own bread was a
very discouraging event and i got ptsd
from that and i'm like i'll never touch
baking go baby steps maybe you should
just try like uh
cookies
oh my god oh my god everything's like
flying everywhere
oh that looks fun yeah it's like
play-doh you made play-doh
what is happening right now what is
happening
also your hair is going to be all in
these tarts
oh my god what is happening i'm learning
from you julia
we're trying to follow our dreams right
now okay this is becoming more and more
of a pipe dream julia
of opening her cafe all right let me let
me get hands on let me help out yeah
you know if i put some junebe matcha in
there i feel like you'd be inventing
flubber right now
oh maybe we should try it like a matcha
crust and a matcha custard later
yes i like that now we're talking that
is beautiful julia
thank you hi nikki what are you doing in
our cooking show
are you trying to eat some egg carts
later oh you're helping yes
next step more water what is this oh
that's the keurig we have a coffee
machine
in our fridge yes a little flex yes
[Music]
so far i've been here for about two
hours and i have no egg part in my mouth
i don't even know why i'm even here
don't you see we are working very hard
right now
you just gotta give it a break
all right so we made the first batch a
normal batch of puff pastry and it's in
the freezer trying to stiffen up again
so we can
work with it because it's starting to
melt on us and that's the thing about
puff pastry is so much butter in it
that'll melt on you if you don't
actually put it into the fridge to
stiffen up again
we're gonna make a second batch now with
a little bit of junky matcha powder to
see if we can make it
green and have a little bit of a matcha
flavor
all right we don't know how much matcha
we're supposed to use
so i'm gonna just ballpark two of these
uh
matcha spoonfuls i say let's go three
three
yeah let's do three let's go three three
four let's go four
[Music]
you might make matcha anything you can
make matcha lattes to go with some
matcha
dantots you can make some matcha rock
star vodka
i can smell the mantra we're putting the
dr seuss spin on it you know what i mean
if you say something yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's that's powerful
make the green come to life i'm more
excited about this
actually because it's not the standard
yeah it's like we're inventing something
we have no idea what we're doing
no idea
[Music]
you got additional help now
uh no all right well you know you're
getting paid in pastries
what is going on there our layers i mean
this is our very sad attempt at layers
but
oh my god this is so exciting beautiful
[Music]
i'm nervous actually the last time i
made egg tarts it wasn't that
hot and it actually triggered my uh my
my smoke alarm
all right here we go shells are ready to
go let's pour
uh let me get you a really really cool
invention that i like using
invented by my peoples we call it a
spoon but i like i like these yeah
they say great spoon a lot more than
your typical uh
[Music]
it happened it happened
[Music]
too hot too hot but it's looking really
good though
[Music]
they look so beautiful
burning wow
oh again i love that sound that's
all for this that look at it you guys
burn it what's happening there yeah it's
a little burnt
it's it's it's it's supposed to be that
way we're working
in progress it's supposed to be that way
okay
okay okay yeah it gives it character all
right moment of truth
yo look at that oh my
the layers oh my god that spiral shape
you see it
oh my good yes i do see it oh that's
amazing
[Music]
and they're popping out so easily too
another problem i ran into was uh so
i used these guys last time and these
guys were a lot harder to
work with in terms of getting the
pastries out these things cling on to
the pastries
not a big fan but the teflon here and
the
muffin tin i'm a fan you should make
needs a teflon actually
that would be great these look so good i
feel like i redeemed myself
as you were saying you're redeeming
yourself
oh no that is a bad element
[Music]
now it's time for the taste test on this
one you're calling this on that right oh
well you guys
why don't you why don't you lick it and
then no one will ever take it there we
go that's yours
that
yay here we go
did you hear the crunch though
this is so good yeah
surprisingly good this is way better
than the ones i made for the video
no seriously pastry homemade perfect
in my head make that you made this like
brush
everything fresh frosting okay that's a
solid eight yeah solid
eight so the like mouth behind my teeth
is burning
nice cute jiggle you got it look at that
flakiness
and it's like filled up too yes extra
custard
yeah nine okay you know what you deserve
a nine
you guys have a nine just good job cause
the dim sum ones are so small that's
true the best things are huge
okay it deserves a knife yay good night
good job guys congrats thank you thank
you
coming up now
[Music]
dude this is so exciting
wow that looks cool okay so
the matcha just turned brown yeah the
crust does not look green whatsoever
yeah not at all
because this thing keeps going off it's
like dr seuss's stream
yeah but chinese a chinese doctor sees
his dream
smell it does it smell like matcha do
you though no
maybe it's just for the color
it's a little undercooked it's okay and
then like the dough here is a little
undercooked too
custard is undercooked undercooked a
little bit it's okay but i've been
eating it because i know what i'm
signing up for if i get a stomachache
tomorrow it's all good
i just want to test out the uh the
matcha flavor and see if it came through
yeah a macho flavor is beautiful the
texture
is lacking a little bit is undercooked
but i'm not mad at it it's good
i'm so sad why is that we should cook it
up but
i didn't want it to burn because it
looked like it was burning pretty badly
maybe the matcha actually affected it
too because we're adding an extra
component to it
maybe but i i will hardly believe it's
because
we made the crust thick this time it's
like oozing out oh no
it was worth a try it was worth a try
[Music]
me